et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
bastide je n'y arrivais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
habitudes
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter alors
tout de suite un message pour dire c'est
pas le vrai on a beau avoir 20 ans
d'interviews avoir reçu la terre entière
y'a pas à dire quand arrive sur le
plateau ça fait le choc quand pour moi
aussi ouais ouais
dis moi quand tu arrives au stade de
france comme ça et cage pour 50000
personnes tels track ou tu la plus c'est
pas trackset et dispose de nervosité qui
vous ronge un petit peu tant qu'on
arrive tant qu'on ça passe quand on
commence à chanter un message pour nous
demander d'où viens-tu johnny en fait
j'ai dit en sport on se connaît pas très
bien en fait moi je suis pas trop là
l'ami des stars c'est vrai je fréquente
pas beaucoup les fréquentent pas les
boîtes que de fréquenter gaz alors on
s'est rencontrés je pense tu te souviens
une fois il ya vingt ans pour
l'interview dans rock et punk qui
s'appelait décembre de polystyrène on
m'a même demandé qu'on me demandait si
un jour tu perdais c'est chaud est ce
que tu fais des implants et j'arrête
quand j'avais entendu dangereux pas
comment va mon avenir
revault je ne mettrai pas les poils de
cul sur la tête
et puis après on s'est croisés comme ça
dans des fêtes à saint tropez mais c'est
vrai on se connaît pas on ne connaît pas
très très bien et notre première vraie
rencontre en fait c'était hier quand je
suis allé visiter la la boîte de nuit
que tu ouvres au pied de la tour
montparnasse
alors j'ai trouvé ça génial il ya parce
que tu es arrivé avec je crois à une
demi heure de retard et tu tes excuses
et trois fois mais c'est extraordinaire
oui c'est normal on avait rendez vous à
trois heures et je suis arrivé
c'est ça une star j'aime pas arriver en
retard tout fait avant j'arrivais
toujours en retard pas une des
meilleures en retard mais 2h20 je
confondais lemay lors du rendez vous
avec l'heure de départ de chez moi et
puis quand j'ai commencé à faire du
cinéma
le premier jour ce révélateur j'avais
toute l'équipe qui était là en stand by
qui attendait quand je suis arrivé ils
m'ont regardé m'ont rien dit et je me
sens je me suis sentie tellement mal que
je suis toujours arriver en avance
y'a des trucs sur les pompes ce jeune
père à l'image quoi la détache il a dû
marcher dans la flotte bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
ici on cyr vraiment l'époque
dis moi tu m'as dit hier que tu
regardais souvent l'émission tout le
monde en parle c'est la soeur sont en
vente la sema géant là je regarde
souvent et que mathilde seigner ouais tu
penses pas du vernis l'est du plateau là
ça donne mauvaise mine à le vert donne
mauvaise milan channel
il y en a bu des choix qu'il va falloir
en sortir de ces deux femmes eurent
imagini tu es un bon look la sava en
bonne forme
ça va oui tu es revenu en début de
semaine d'une cure laurent ça peut
intéresser de biologie ah oui c'est
debout à 6 heures et quart avant juin en
danse est une science qui s'intéressent
au vieillissement psychophysique ans et
ça c'est un peu d'âme et de la médecine
chinoise
ouais et on voit un petit peu tout ce
qui va pas longtemps encore que ce soit
le foie les intestins ra les poumons les
abats quoi encore un groupe célèbre
conte sérieuse au passage nous et a bien
réussi dit non non il surperforme way
fais gaffe quand même parce que c'est un
truc pour rajeunir donc avec laeticia un
jour c'est qui laetitia laetitia
laeticia hallyday
je verrai pas sa femme oui j'avais nati
- 4ème et riche
je vais corriger c'est pas grave el al
dans l'art c'est chiant etc lancé ça
laurence pas complice et bien sûr après
12 ans jean david sa radio ni way david
messas grand david hallyday vient
souvent que j'avais anthony mois laura
ça va leur arriver de mazarine merci est
en train de tourner en ce moment avait à
nouveau film ça s'est bien passé le
premier la bleue très bien il gèle un
gros succès il allait très heureux parce
que tant la deuxième fils qui va trajet
espérons qu'il sera bien alors
maintenant johnny comme c'est la
première fois que je te reçois je vais
te faire une interview première fois
[Musique]
alors joli ton premier non tout le monde
croit que c'est smet
en fait c'est clair comme julien c'est
le nom de ta mère parce que ton père
était assez volage il a attend moi j'ai
claude moine
les stagiaires devront supporter étant
père était quelqu'un d'assez bas
tellement fait pour la pas tellement
fait pour la pour la vie de famille et
quelques jours après la naissance il a
vendu les meubles y la troupe du moulin
y est
dix jours après la naissance il grandit
vite et huit mois plus tard il a quitté
le domicile conjugal et donc ta mère
s'est retrouvé comme ça toute seule et
elle a retrouvé un an après elle a
obligé à l'épouser mais ton vrai nom ton
vrai premier non c'est clair mais ce
domaine c'est huguette clair jusqu'au
mariage
au mariage de ma mère c'était clair qui
était mannequin chez fat
oui une très jolie femme qui vit
toujours et qui vit toujours criant
comme je crois qu'elle est à dire
réussit quand même quoi qu'on en dise
ayew mais bon être la maman de johnny
doit être finement joué déni du troc à
un oui mais bon j'ai bien du souci alors
ce père léon se mettent donc johnny vous
le reverrez vingt ans plus tard vous
vous avez 21 ans fait le service
militaire en allemagne
et un jour il ya un mec qui vous dit
fois les à l'entrée de la caserne
on vous y allez c'est un ordre vous y
allez et à ce moment là vous voyez un
type qui se jettent sur vous en disant
johnny johnny monfils est en vous
mettant à un ours en peluche dans les
bras et c'était votre père et quelques
années plus tard vous apprendrez qu'en
fait c'était un coup qu'il avait monté
avec les paparazzi ouais enfin bon ça
s'est passé
ouais je préfère pas
trop parler de ce à quoi vous l'avez
vachement lait après quand même votre
père non oui en trois gp ce que j'ai pu
mais c'était pas toujours facile parce
que j'avais pris à l'appartement et puis
je reçois des coups de téléphone dans la
nuit comme quoi il avait mis le feu à
l'appartement il est là mais non j'ai
j'ai essayé beaucoup de choses puis à un
moment donné j'ai baissé les bras
un message pour dire que tu me pique mes
veines excitant non c'est vrai qu'en
voulu acheter des costumes cerrutti
d'aller les revendre quand quand vous
lui louer un appartement y mettez le feu
effectivement donc c'était assez assez
désespérant tunnel monde cet été comme
il était alors c'est vous d'abord manger
baisser les bras la vie qu'il voulait
d'abord reggiani vous à vous a parlé de
lui une fois qu'un jour je rencontrais
djallit qui me dit tu sais je sais que
tu as eu une mauvaise impression de
temps permet moi j'allais prendre des
cours tous les tous les week-ends à
bruxelles chez lui c'était un professeur
d'art dramatique et ordinaire et puis un
jour vous allez l'enterrement de ce père
un petit peu inconnu d'une certaine
façon à un cheikh des camps en belgique
j'ai vraie excuse mais ce qui m'a
attristé ce qui va d'abord étonné mais
surtout attristé c'est que j'étais tout
seul ouais c'est bien la première faute
était tout seul
oui un peu mais c'était pas gai dans
cette histoire c'est un petit peu
déboussolé un d'une certaine façon c'est
tandis que vous avez eue après de créer
une famille et pas y arriver c'est
peut-être dû à sa fille avant de s'en
faire de la psychanalyse à deux balles
c'est peut-être ça l'histoire non il
faut d'abord avant de créer une famille
il faut tomber sur la mode personne
n'était jamais tombé sur la bonne
personne et cette fois-ci bon cette fois
ci je crois je suis dit attendez ouais
ça al'air attendait sur une fois l'ex
ordinaire qui je suis très heureux et
belle était temps parce que alors vous
avez été élevé par votre tante hélène
marais votre première scène c'est à 4
ans vous en souvenez de ça en 47 à
londres non dans dans une pièce ce qui
s'appelle caligula de camus fait le rôle
d'un petit nez que j'en parle pas du
tout premier souvenir me souvenais c'est
à londres
bull coincé le doigt
un rail d'escalators en soule est je
vais le doit être complètement achevé la
première guitare quel âge vers avoir
tout genre ouais vous étiez à rome avec
vos cousins des stars elie et vous avez
à ce moment-là rencontré un guitariste
de flamenco
il choisit une tournée théâtrale un
époque là où il y avait comme ça des tas
de numéro 2 de music hall 1 il y avait
des gitans et avait des acrobates bon et
il y avait dans la troupe des gitans il
y avait un guitariste flamenco qui m'a
appris à jouer un peu de guitare
la jota la rue d'arleux plein de choses
et ça m'a vraiment plu et ensuite on m'a
acheté une guitare donc avec des cordes
à caen ska et 14000 ont confirmé le
retour au flamenco bientôt bientôt
premier rôle au cinéma 1954 en semaine
et diabolique
vous aviez une petite annonce dans
france soir et comme il n'est pas de blé
à la maison votre temps que vous avez
emmené là bas j'ai passé un casting et
ouais dans l'état dans la classe
d'enfants mais j'étais à figuration ses
parts au vin j'avais 2,3 à dire qui a
été coupée donc les deux le pas très bon
mais on vous voit dans le film vous vous
lavez les danses et or premier cachet de
johnny hallyday en 1955 à hanovre
premier cachet c'est un coca cola vous
aviez chanter davy crockett sur scène si
souvient de ses chansons de l'époque est
d'avis que j'ai chanté en duo avec
johnny j'ai fait mon premier duo avec
génie
c'était en 2003 vous êtes montés très
très tôt sur les planches à repasser ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on découvre mais c'est
normal parce que j'ai été élevé par une
par une famille d'artistes engagés
beaucoup qui faisait beaucoup music hall
beaucoup de cabaret donc je voyais pas
très honnêtement je ne voyais pas
comptable plus tard voyez plutôt
artistes bon ça doit quand même perturbé
sa d'être sur scène aussitôt non non
c'est comme j'ai comme j'en ai fait mon
métier c'est plutôt une chance pour un
juge ait eu le temps d'apprendre avant
d'être connu maintenant ce que je
m'attends à ce que ce que je reproche un
petit peu c'est qu'on lance d'aider des
gens on essaie de leur apprendre à
danser à chanter en quatre mois on les
lance comme des stars ils n'ont pas le
temps ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas dit
non ils n'ont pas eu la commande irles
la formation la formation
si jani merci beaucoup jeanine de
strasbourg pour four pour aller sur une
scène d'être langer comme star il faut
apprendre son métier avant et on leur
laisse pas le temps d'apprendre dans
effectivement quand on les voit sur
c'est la première fois les gens peu fait
peut-être déçu ce n'est pas que le fait
chaud de chantier qui est important
c'est le fait de savoir aller sortir
d'une scène et les savoir bouger sur une
selle en fait un forain quoi je le suis
un oui en quelque sorte oui c'est pas
péjoratif
non non pas du juge adore les forums
alors première bagarre c'était avec la
bombe de la trinité non j'imagine y
avait du tronc il y avait longue crise y
avait dit michele cercone preniez des
dérouillées par les mecs de la bande du
sacré coeur où la bande de la bastille
ouais ils étaient plus nombreux que les
pieds combien vaut hall où elles étaient
une vingtaine un essai deux ans c'était
plié
votre première petite amie vous en
souvenez ma première petite amie rivers
de la trappe
non
[Applaudissements]
on va voir qui s'en souvient qu elle
vous regarde mais elle est la première
petite amie c'est claude pécha bravo à
elle
et johnny l'a ramené en train puisque à
l'épaule que vous n'aviez pas encore de
voiture alors votre première idole c'est
brassens c'est vrai ce que vous auriez
voulu avoir brassens avec les grosses
musulmans bleus où il est il rassurant
pas de brel aussi c'est une de vos
premières idoles et et vous dit s'il
avait fait du rock qui nous aurait tous
enterrés
c'est vrai parce que il chante avec sa
poésie les îles la terre pointé sur
scène avec l'énergie et le désespoir
d'un rockeur je ne connais pas d'autres
chanteurs que brel 1 qui transpirait
autant qu'il vomissait avant de rentrer
sur scène alors que tous les records le
bovespa avant et qui tracent pluri qui
zonaient qui seront faire autant kaka
kaka chemin de broadway
vous trouvez ça bien là qu'on réédite
des choses qu'ils voulaient pas voir
éditer écouter tout le monde évidemment
curieux d'entendre ça mais par rapport à
sa mémoire je trouve pas ça très bien
alors dit moi il ya des trucs un toit
comme ça qui ont été faits que que
personne n'a entendu et derrière leurs
quelques effets réallumer le feu serait
celui jamais senti en ta première qu'est
ce que t'en souviens ouest et une
triumph boulangerie brune tr3 18 ans dès
qu'il a eu l'âge un première boîte
août est sorti au thé rentrée déjà way
première doit toucher sortie alors là ça
c'est pas j'en ai fait beaucoup
la première à l'époque de la banque de
la trinité j'imagine non à leurs jours à
gaudreault et c'est sa première - comme
propriétaire c'est celle qui ouvre seuil
2003 voilà 2003 je rappelle la forme
2003 pour que johnny hallyday et sa
boîte à lui ouais mais ça une histoire
cette boîte que que j'ai monté là on va
en parler en volume contre cette voie
que c'est une histoire de coeur en fête
c'est absolument ans et j'ai rencontré
j'ai rencontré laëtitia il ya neuf ans à
miami
ouais et
c'est ma assez drôle d'ailleurs parce
qu'à l'époque jean roch travailler pour
andré boudou le père de laeticia
le père du disparu et il me téléphone
j'étais à l'hôtel une télé fox devait
partir le disais que tu fais cela je dis
rien je que les premiers à mym dit si tu
veux on dit dans son jus d'accord ils
arrivent en voiture avec andré boudou
laetitia et la femme d'andré on va dîner
après on va on va à l'amnesia de miami
de miami et puis la soeur espace on va
dans votre boîte est bon on rentre tard
et que le lendemain je revois laetitia
et puis je rentre sur paris et donc je
rentre sur paris on a continué à ce
téléphone etc
et puis un mois après laetitia giry
vittel effet à paris elle devait rester
une semaine et puis elle n'est jamais
repartie
elle avait un billet vert oui mais il
n'a jamais servi le brc pas remboursés
j'ai voulu faire j'ai voulu faire par
rapport à par rapport à l'endroit où je
leur apporterai je voulais faire la
boîte de nuit à paris j'y suis allé hier
donc c'est là qu'on sait qu'on s'est
connus on pourrait dire mais on a fait
un petit reportage
[Musique]
la baule et reconstituer l'ambiance de
miami
c
[Musique]
la ja barre comme une barre d'audard
trois heures pendant avec les jours les
6 me permet dans huit jours à vous elle
est habillée commet le moins possible
j'espère sexy sexy il au fond qu'est-ce
qu'il va y avoir là une cascade d'eau 1
d'accord un qui entoure la tête
alors là ici ça c'est les caissons de
basses en un avec un mais au dessus on
va avoir des civils en produit superfeed
comme par hasard les dj ce sera toi zidi
salut kery chanter clarté que j'étais dj
mois 1
à 16 ans on risque à nouveau je n'ai pas
tué la bonne attaque concurrents
[Musique]
m
la commune jean kiffer à venir ici à peu
près 1500 1800 1
c'est quoi la boîte que tu as préféré
que tout est dit si tu devais pas par
celle là puisque c'est toi qui l'a quand
même mieux plus jeune j'ai tout le temps
c'est l elysée matignon ça n'existe plus
et rendez dans le circuit mais comme
pour les vip lisible qu'est ce que fait
alors le labour est en train de se
mettre dans la rue mais où quoi qu'on
devient souvent ouais je viens tous les
soirs ouais mais l'ancien c'est utile
mais pour moi c'est une occasion de
ressortir le début c'est vrai que
dernièrement je sortais plus parce que
je m'ennuyais dans les boîtes ne trouvez
pas vraiment les la boîte où je veux
m'amuser comme avoir vu on a quatre
sorties de secours plus la sortie pour
les
les gens handicapés donc ça va on peut
allumer le feu ça
je
c'est parfait ça fait très été un mois
je présenterai si je dois je les gens
s'amusent ainsi que je te connais je
pourrais tu peux venir bateau soit dans
des soirées spéciales lui va y avoir des
soirées spéciales
non pas tant parce que lui quand il est
spécial bon c'est vrai bon bah écoute on
va se voir peut-être plus souvent que
depuis vingt ans on était une boîte
ouais bien sûr mais tu sais moi je parle
je ne veux pas faire de concurrence aux
autres quoi donner matière j'ai plein
d'amis dans le nuit kurdes ou le bois
toi jean roch c'est pas la même chose
le queen c'est pas le même principe on
est tous amis on se croit que plus tôt
on se complète plutôt main plutôt que de
faire la tire beaucoup d'e mails pour
dire qu'est ce que c'est que cette boîte
le quoi le cuir
les krills bien alors jenny comme
maintenant tes patrons de boîtes de nuit
on va faire l'interview wat tv
bon alors c'est un gage de
questionnaires de pousser comme dans les
boîtes de nuit à l'idée
ou le camp de
quand j'entends déjà les
[Applaudissements]
pas encore pour quelle faute à tu le
plus indulgent
la faiblesse
quel
personnage historique à paris
paris
robin des bois quelle est ta qualité
l'humour est celle attendent la
tendresse
tu aurais tu aimé récit n'était pas
génial
jean gabin
oh
c'était dur
tu m'as pas
d'un gabarit de 36 heures
que tu déteste par dessus tout
mes deux fils
comment aimerais tu mourir
quel est le temps présent de forêt
super bien sûr ici avec toi là bien
est-ce que
oui
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]